what I want to talk to you about in my
brief time is the scholarly
communication Institute and I'll echo
some comment comment that was made by
Peter Brantley the executive director of
the digital library Federation yesterday
in his opening remarks and that is for
SC I for the scholarly communication
Institute video is somewhat a new
development and we're thinking with the
communities that we're working with how
we're really going to integrate that
where it makes sense to integrate it and
in some respects what I'm talking to you
about is a social process with scholars
that we've been going through the
scholarly communication Institute is a
six year project and that we're
currently in our fifth year and it's
been generally it generously funded by
the andrew mellon foundation it's housed
at the University of Virginia in
Charlottesville even though i divide my
time between San Francisco and Cape Cod
and I will I guess explain a little
later on what I mean by house at the
University of Virginia one of the
motivating factors of melon wanting to
fund this Institute was the desire of
those of us who have been working with
individual projects over the years
innovative projects in digital
scholarship to move the scholarly
communities beyond individual projects
and to move them merely to a cultural
change and both we and melon were
interested in doing that to just give
you some background on myself so you
understand the perspective I'm coming
from I spent most of my career as a
university librarian at places like UC
San Francisco Dartmouth College johns
hopkins medical institution and i was
the founding university librarian for
the california digital library and the
founding of university of california's
east scholarship program before that I
worked on what were considered very
forward-looking electronic projects like
the red sage project which was one of
the first large journal projects
electronic journal product projects that
brought together 20 medical and
scientific publishers and created a very
large database and critical mass of
content for people to move forward in
was really kind of proof of concept back
in the 90s of wood electronic journals
really work and where faculty and
students really interested in them and I
know for many of you here that seems
like something that that's just a given
unfortunately it is for people prior to
that I spent much of my time in the
medical arena in with the Human Genome
Project in developing databases and
resources and social spaces for Human
Genetics researches and molecular
biologists and I did this all from the
platform of the library because my
strong feeling is that the library needs
to be at the center of all scholarship
and even though there are parts of me
that become dismayed when I see what
happens in the real world that very much
drives me as well the scholarly
communication Institute I think it's
useful you know to define first of all
what we're really about really about
scholarly communication and what that
means to us anyway is a cyclical process
that takes researchers faculty members
scholars to the research and discovery
process
analysis presentation preservation
dissemination access and use and all the
way again in a cyclical fashion back to
research and discovery and this is a
process that's been in existence in some
form or another for many many years and
the digital revolution has had a real
significant impact on various parts of
this process at different times
depending upon what technology you're
talking about in the scholarly
communication Institute we deal
primarily with humanities scholars and
the reason of that one reason for that
of course is melons interest in the arts
and humanities and one of the most
difficult things that we have to deal
with with humanities scholars is the
notion of scholarship as a collaborative
process and not as an individual
enterprise when I worked with a
scientific community there was not much
need to put emphasis and focus on that
but there is indeed in the humanities
and it takes our working with groups of
scholars for long periods of time before
many of them are really able to make
that change at least in certain
institute in institute situations the
overall goal of the institute is to
create an opportunity for scholars to
understand and embrace digital
scholarship we just don't want to have
them sit around the room and talk about
digital scholarship talk about why they
can't do digital scholarship or what
they can't do or what latest technology
has caused them problems but we actually
want to take them from where they are to
doing things we assist the scholars by
bringing together with the scholars
leadership from scholarly societies
research libraries advanced technologies
experts and critical arenas such as
copyright higher education leadership
that often holds the resource key and
private industry more and more we're
trying to
private industry into this process to
what we refer to as an institute and
over the six years there are six
Institute's there is a summer meeting in
that meeting has always held at the
University of Virginia and that's in
some respects why we say this is housed
at the University of Virginia we invite
a very small group hopefully no more
than 25 and at least sixty percent of
those to be working scholars to a very
conversational kind of meeting we early
on ply them with food and alcohol and
find that they are very cooperative
during the entire rest of the time what
we hope to do it there is to create some
communities of action that are then
going to go out in a disciplinary way
not in an individual scholar kind of way
on a particular project to create some
real advances in digital scholarship
whether you're talking about digital
scholarship as you know at the initial
phase of research and discovery are you
talking about it from a publication
phase etc we also bring to the summer
meeting usually three to six graduate
students and we find that the graduate
students have a tremendous impact on the
senior scholars in attempting to explain
to them what they really need for their
careers to develop and how they would
like to develop their careers and what
the constraints are for them if they
can't practice digital scholarship in
moving their ideas forward creating new
knowledge and new analysis I'm going to
single out a couple of Institute's that
we did so you can see how this
progresses if I go back to the second
one SC I too was on practical ethics and
practical ethics things like biomedical
ethics and journalistic ethics
environmental ethics legal ethics
business ethics in other words applying
ethical standards
in various fields we brought together a
group of practical ethicists from all
those kinds of areas in different
institutions and this was a group that
essentially had rarely used the
technology except potentially to access
some citation database and we tried to
immerse them immediately and what all
the possibilities might be in the
discussions for those 22 days we're
really quite significant and they also
had a significant effect on what those
scholars did when they left the
Institute the second thing that we try
to do with them is create communities of
action and we created two communities of
action a group from biomedical ethics
and now a group from journalistic
journalistic ethics and the real advance
in digital scholarship that we're
working on with them three years later
still is the creation of packets here
which is really a community space and
also a very large resource of all kinds
of digital information from citation
based to full text to video to newspaper
to Flickr images everything really
that's out there and we're in the
planning and prototype phase with them
at this stage and what's been really
critical is not to have an institute
whereby we bring these people together
and then let them go but you know when
once they get home we want to make sure
that they're continually brought
together from across those institutions
and continue to work on some of these
questions the fourth Institute last year
was in architectural history and there
are probably some more immediate
applications with respect to video in
architectural history what we brought
together was a group of architectural
historians and early on when we were
planning the Institute we had hope to
bring together
actual historians and architects given
the fact of everything that's happened
with architectural design the fact that
most of most plans and most as builts
these days are in digital form but
there's such a gulf distance and how
people think of architectural historians
think and how how architects practicing
architects even in the academic
environment thing that we felt that we
couldn't bridge that gap well that was
kind of a noble thing to do that we
would concentrate on architectural
history I I've left the communities of
action the wrong one here the
communities of action that we created
were really around a community of action
with respect to publication and a
community of action with respect to
knowledge gathering and the real
advances that we're trying to make in
digital scholarship with respect to
architectural history is the Journal of
the Society of architectural historians
online is now being developed in
accordance with art store which I sure
you understand was also developed as a
melon project and this is not just an
online journal rather because the
journal in its you know current print
form is already online but this is now a
journal that is seeking and working with
submissions that come in very different
technological forms because people in
architectural history and architecture
and classics and other kinds of areas
you know are really dealing a lot with
computer modeling and design and so it
becomes a very different kind of
resource for people to access and also a
very different kind of resource for
people to begin to publishing to get
their work out in that there was no
place for them to get there
about in before the other is in the
creation of an architecture visual
resource network and the notion here is
to capture the work of scholars as they
begin to capture information themselves
architectural historians go everywhere
with their cameras they now go
everywhere with your digital cameras
they also go everywhere with their
camera phones now and they also go
everywhere with some kind of video
device and what ARVN will be is a
resource that allows people to input all
of those resources to have some vetting
process that then moves them from what
the architectural historians are calling
a pig pile just that information that
gets brought from everywhere else
embedded into a database that's
available for access that's been
sanctioned by the Society of
architectural historians and again we're
working with art store and we're also
we're following two models really the
art store model which is a more
traditional model and the Flickr model
and we're able to compare what kinds of
things you know the differences in the
values of tagging versus very structured
metadata things that are just out there
and easily captured versus image quality
that needs to be images that need to be
of such quality to be able to publish
etc etc SC i5 which happens this summer
takes a slightly different tack rather
than rather than take a discipline we're
taking the notion of visual studies
across disciplines because our
understanding and our belief is that the
visual whether it's in still form a
moving form is is a really critical area
for universities and academic
to deal with both in developing an
infrastructure to support them and
providing other kinds of support for
faculty and students etc and so we're
bringing scholars who work with media
together visual media together some of
the scholars come from video some come
the video world something out of the
film world some come out of new media
new media are some time from simulations
they're using 3d that you standard
photography and and we really want to
focus them in on what's the critical
aspect of visual media is for their work
what are the research agendas that need
to be developed in order to really
understand the infrastructures that need
to put need to be put into place and one
of the things that we've been able to do
in this institute that we weren't with
architectural historians is to bring
together both theorists and
practitioners and in fact out of the 25
people that we have coming to the
Institute we did not invite anybody who
was either a theorist or a practitioner
but people who are both theorists and
practitioners because we feel that that
integration of the tube is absolutely
critical to moving forward and what we
hope to develop this summer is now a
community of action which is a visual
scholarship community of action and
until we have that summer institute
meeting we really don't know what the
communities of action are going to
exactly look like and what kind of real
advances we think we can make with that
community of action one of the ones
that's clearly on online right now is
the development of a research agenda
because we think that that's really key
and SF is very interested in that
addition to melon neh is very interested
as you may know they have a major new
program that they're announcing on
Centers for digital humanities and they
don't have much money yet because they
don't know what it is they want to do
and we really want to influence them
have the scholars influence them and
give these scholars who are at that
meeting this summer or community go back
and do that with the last Institute is
going to be held in the summer of 2008
and it really focuses on the notion of
centers of excellence I imagine that
most of you are familiar with the cyber
infrastructure report that came out of
the American Council of learned
societies on the notion of cyber
infrastructure in the social sciences
and humanities and that was really
developed on a model from one that had
come previously from NSF on cyber
infrastructure in the sciences and some
of the recommendations that are in there
have to do with the creation of centers
of excellence but it doesn't specify
what the centers of excellence are what
they would do where they would be and
what we're in the process of doing right
now is working closely with acls Council
and librarian information resources
melon neh NSF people who work now with
the Centers for digital humanities and
coming up with a number of models for
what those centers might be and some of
those models frankly may center around
specific technologies so that we need to
have a center of excellence that focuses
on video or that focuses on textual
information etc we'll move forward with
those models and create communities of
action that will then have a set of
strategies to make sure funding gets put
in place by both federal and private
agencies
and that implementation begins to move
forward s CI is not only about
discussion it's really about making
something happen and making something
happen in the broad community and trying
to leverage what has been done in
individual projects at many of the
institutions previous to this thang